first make a spicy paste by crushing
garlic in a pestle and water along with
paprika
sea salt
and olive oil
spoon the paste onto fillets of mackerel
and a great inexpensive oily fish that's
really healthy and leave to marinade
when ready to eat put the mackerel
fillets on a baking tray Inside Out
season and roast in a hot oven
next make a Tangy potato salad
for the dressing mix Dijon mustard white
wine vinegar
olive oil and saffron and whisk until
blended
[Music]
four new potatoes in salted water drain
and lightly Crush
add sliced spring onion and Spoon in the
vinaigrettes
[Music]
to serve top the potato salad with the
roasted mackerel and drizzle with more
vinaigrette
[Music]
[Applause]